- Just so you know before
she comes, she's someone
you kind of have to get used to.
- What does that mean?
- Hey guys.
- Hi!
(upbeat music)
- You ready to go?
- Yep, how's this?
- No.
- How about this?
Oh you've got to be kidding me, right?
Oh my God, I can't even
believe I made it here.
Seriously, first my car
wouldn't start, then my
neighbor just like
piles all his trash into
my trash can, I have this
whole bag of recycling.
I recycle, and I couldn't
even fit it in there,
it was ridiculous.
Why am I still standing
with this, happy bithday.
- Thank you.
- I'm sorry.
- Okay, so that just about wraps it up.
- Actually I have a few questions.
- Oh my God Melanie, did
he tell you about that time
that he got really really
drunk and wet his pants
and everybody saw and he cried?
- No.
- No?
Okay, don't tell him I told you that.
- Oh look what Melanie sent.
- [Gray Shirt] Oh.
- What?
- Do you want me to be nice or honest?
Where is our food, seriously?
It's been like 20 minutes.
- No.
- Yeah, it's been forever, seriously.
Are you guys seeing this?
This is ridiculous, come on!
I can't make this stuff up,
I gotta get back to work!
- Do you wanna go back to the movies?
- I wanna be outside today.
- Beach.
- I don't like sand.
- Okay, the park?
- Grassy.
- You wanna just stay in?
- No, that's so boring.
- [Bar Tender] That'll
be 10 dollars please.
- 10 dollars, that's expensive!
Just saying.
Put it on my tab.
(bleep) balls, mother (bleep)
(bleeping)
(groaning)
Sorry.
- This?
- Aw, you look really
good, you're so handsome.
Let's go.
- Yes, I am so hungry.
(upbeat music)